I think Selena is incredibly talented
James Franco gets candid about Selena
Gomez and explains why he cast her in
his new movie in dubious battle in a
role like you've never seen
Selena before it's not about you and me
it's about Lisa's kid and what kind of
world he's gonna grow up man why is it
that she impresses you so much she
hasn't done you know tons of like movies
like this and I even said that to me
like when I asked her dude she's like
yes I want to be I want to be a part of
your world I want to try and I'm gonna
go on this adventure and I kind of
thought I I felt like I had a secret
weapon that I could put her in and she
would nail it and she did follow one is
just a simple clean life how did you as
a director help her channel her motherly
instincts for a role like this that
birthing scene was something else that
was next-level I sort of knew that she
did have those instincts and she's
maternal in a lot of ways and I just
thought if we do this scene I know
swimming is just gonna give everything
for it was almost like a piece of
performance art he had multiple cameras
we were in there and we just like kept
it going we had a real nerve so we got a
real baby we had all you know all this
stuff and and we just kind of did it all
I see is danger
you